so Ronnie gets in the holiday spirit by
covering every square inch of his little
yard with inflatable decorations like
inflatable snow globes inflatable cars
but the crown jewel of his collection is
this 9 foot inflatable dragon which has
nothing to do with Christmas
and really the tackiest thing I've ever
seen this year we decided to go over and
record Ronnie and his fiancee Stephanie
putting up their decorations uh-huh what
I found out was bear that couple that
bites all the time oh yeah and they
think it's cute I don't know if they're
soulmates or like they should be legally
separated right it's scary and it's
constant constant the arguing started
early and never stopped I'm gonna play
you uh Chris's report now we still got
three more watch McCall it's dad why not
because we're not doing the book we
didn't do it we didn't know we didn't
because it gets caught on my car I know
but we did it but we plugged it in over
there and everything plugged in over
there no we didn't oh I can see in the
[ __ ] background we not argue with me
in things that pictures from night last
year last year it's [ __ ] dead last
year go [ __ ] yourself okay yeah well I
saw all up with you later oh wow the
sound of love that's taking up with her
later well I asked her and she said what
that means is he's just gonna mope all
day
he'll just mope all night and all day
Ronnie's a weirdo well here he is acting
like her supervisor all right he's just
standing off to the side and his arms
are crossed and when she asked for help
he gets angry here all right which way
do you want this now give me the boy in
[ __ ] boy and you want the boy yes yes
great see why you let her do what you
want to do now leave me a [ __ ] alone you
see what I mean oh I remember how I did
it last year so that I what this never
mind I Know Who I did it last year see
see you blame it on way to [ __ ] see
Hey
blame it on me it's not me it's her what
is he what's going on with him you have
to understand - like she's crawling
through bushes and climbing ladders and
here Ronnie makes Stephanie climb a
ladder to hang the lights and then his
contribution is grabbing
he's up to sexual hijinks hey I get to
hold or at the best part hey I get to
hold her ass that's great I'm not doing
anything you from falling over yeah yeah
case you lose your balance I got the
ladder and I got her ass anybody else
want to hold her up what do you make of
this Robin it doesn't sound like fun now
Ronnie as we said Ronnie isn't coming to
the office Christmas party this year and
even that led to an argument between
them you go into a destination wedding
yes and that's my Christmas gift
[ __ ] no to vacation part it's not a
vacation we have to go because of a
freakin wedding march plays occasion
when you pick by somewhere what would
you like from Ronnie
um I'm not asking for much there's a
it's really weird it's a Dyson hairdryer
that I want one that you put your ugly
head on
what's good what's he doing that it was
weird and like all the neighbors can
hear it everyone's staring and it yeah
it's like it's like dinner theater you
know do the other neighbors have those
really tacky decorations no I think like
a lot of the houses are really big and
really nice I think this kind of
Ronnie's way of like saying hey look at
me like it's a way to get attention when
he's not at work Ronnie's out in the
hall screaming that you're wrong come on
defend yourself
well now he's gonna fight with you here
comes what would you in the corner ugly
and all this [ __ ] man
ugly you're ugly head around goofing
around dude it's not funny you're gonna
blow it and then he tells me he says
that none of my neighbors two houses
down here look it's twice as much [ __ ]
on the [ __ ] law here I'll play it
open your [ __ ] eyes or get new
glasses
the biggest fight of the day talking
about the biggest fight of the day took
place while they were hanging lights we
asked if they had put up a Christmas
tree inside the house Ronnie said they
had him because Stephanie's too lazy
what she likes doing that inside of the
house [ __ ] lazy to do it do you work
a 40-hour week nobody else ever worked
before this time it's not an oem work
it's that you don't work now exactly I
earned it right now I need to work come
home cook clean and do it or anything
you don't worry because I want to [ __ ]
you don't cook you don't [ __ ] clean
you got a cleaning lady you don't have
to [ __ ] do nothing that's because I
work [ __ ] [ __ ] off I would clean house
if you yeah I would clean the house
ya know you only know how to slob up the
house with you and your dog [ __ ] I
know you how many years now twelve and
double clean the [ __ ] house once
Jesus you're a bear I looked at Turner
screws man you're like why put up
decorations at all you're not jolly the
day was anything but jolly now I don't
know what's going on with this
relationship but here's a quick montage
of all the fighting we did it's right
behind the [ __ ]
better than that family behind the wall
don't [ __ ] yourself okay you just didn't
like the swoop
let's go and a pee at a car would be
very organized you throw [ __ ] everywhere
oh this is awesome zvr and I could have
stopped the car Oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
dammit I don't like going into the
[ __ ] city like you want to do I have
won once have I ever asked you go in the
city [ __ ] yourself okay I don't have to
explain this to you jackass I can't wait
to you to run a business together
it's gonna be great yeah dude I can't
even believe you got that beautiful
young girl at home yeah and we have a
great time she treat her a little bit
nicer no we have a blast dude you don't
even dude did you or did you not have a
big fight the night before
dude don't don't [ __ ] get into my
[ __ ] business okay cuz you're getting
a little too deep into it right you're
saying [ __ ] it's not true okay and I
don't think I'd let you cover anything
in my house again it it is not [ __ ]
happening
Deva it's like I'm a diva it will not
happen
it looks like Walmart took a [ __ ] on
your lawn whatever the [ __ ] you want
okay